vous êtes dangereux pour vous vous êtes
dangereux pour les autres c'est par ces
mots que la présidente a accompagné la
décision du tribunal concernant le
jugement de cet homme de 54 ans reconnu
coupable de dix incendies dans une
petite commune de haute saône 220
habitants pourtant là bas l'homme qui
avait avoué les faits l'année dernière
lorsqu'il avait été interpellé ce matin
il est totalement essayer de se
disculper en disant que ce n'était pas
lui qu'il n'avait jamais allumer ces
incendies dans la salle il ya la partie
civile il ya les gens qui ont été
victimes de ces incendies
et pour eux aujourd'hui la décision du
tribunal est un véritable soulagement
propose d'écouter l'une des avocates des
parties civiles on a une personne
dangereuse qui va se retrouver sous les
verrous pendant quatre ans avec une
interdiction de paraître au village ce
qui nous semblait fondamental parce que
compte tenu de ses 15 ans s'enduit sur
une période de quatre années il fallait
que ça cesse et que le village puisse
reprendre sa sérénité et sa quiétude
dans sa plaidoirie l'avocat de la
défense a essayé d'expliquer au tribunal
que des pas possible que son client soit
mêlé à tous ces incendies qu'il y avait
un défaut évident de preuves matérielles
quoi qu'il en soit le tribunal a suivi
le réquisitoire du procureur et condamne
donc le prévenu à quatre ans de prison
avec un suivi de trois ans sa sortie de
détention et une interdiction de se
rendre dans le village de bras les loups
et vert fontaine dans cette commune où
on espère très rapidement tourner la
page de cette psychose